al nuevo código de las familias con más
del 66% de los votos La Isla le dio el
visto bueno al matrimonio igualitario y
a la adopción por parte de parejas del
mismo sexo así como a la subrogación de
vientres y al reconocimiento legal de
varios padres y madres además de los
biológicos me alegro muchísimo En
definitiva yo creo que lo más importante
es que un código que responde a este
tiempo a este tiempo y tenemos que
admitir que es lo que nos conviene el
referendo promovido por el presidente
Miguel Díaz canel fue el primero en
abarcar temas diferentes a reformas
constitucionales pero a pesar de su
aprobación la abstensión fue una de las
protagonistas de la jornada con una tasa
del 26%. siendo la participación más
baja de una votación desde 1959 cuando
triunfó la revolución de Fidel Castro
una victoria agridulce para el gobierno
pero que no impidió el presidente
celebrar los resultados
ganó el sí se ha hecho justicia a probar
el código de las familias es hacer
justicia es al dar una deuda con varias
generaciones de cubanos y cubanas cuyos
proyectos de familia llevan años
esperando por esta ley a partir de hoy
Seremos una nación mejor
sin embargo el código tuvo sus
detractores sobre todo por parte de las
iglesias protestantes y católica otros
En cambio no aceptaban la totalidad del
texto
hay algunas cosas bien y uno y otra cosa
tan que tan mal
a pesar de alguna resistencia es para
muchos se trata de salvar una deuda con
parte de la comunidad lgtbiq más quienes
vieron sus derechos vulnerados sobre
todo en las décadas de 1960 y 1970
cuando el gobierno enviaba a personas
homosexuales a campos militarizados de
trabajo agrícola